[Musik]
liebe durchhaltewillen und große träume
im schatten des everest im zentrum das
junge paar norbu sherpa und die
schweizer anwältin andrea zimmermann
vor zwei jahren wollten sie gemeinsam
den mount everest besteigen
[Musik]
aber alles kam ganz anders am 25 april
2015 bebte die erde
das erdbeben kostete 9000 menschen das
leben und hinterließ eine spur der
zerstörung im ganzen land
statt auf den everest zu steigen
begannen euro und andrea sofort zu
helfen
als erstes verteilten sie nahrungsmittel
in abgelegenen dörfern und erlebten die
not der bevölkerung hautnah
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eineinhalb jahre später fuhren sie
dorthin zurück
das ist der platz des hauses er hat mais
gepflanzt und die steine darüber gelegt
die leute leben immer noch in solchen
blechen
[Musik]
die landeshauptleute passiert
nur wer geld besitzt konnte brown
norbu und andrea haben ihr tracking
business wieder aufgenommen und sie
gaben sich das jawort
nach sherpa tradition eine
interkulturelle
[Musik]
darauf erfüllten sie sich ihren alten
traum
den everest
[Musik]
am 21 mai 2016 standen sie gemeinsam auf
den höchsten gipfel der welt
für mich wahnsinnig wichtig sie dass ich
nicht noch mal offen ist aber ob es
fotos machen und das wollen sie
ihr neues ziel der aufbau einer schule
in laptop mit hilfe von spenden und
freiwilligen aus der schweiz
[Musik]
lern jia sei das zaubert der everest
region
andrea und norbert genießen einen der
seltenen momente der zweisamkeit
[Musik]
recep asam hat sich vom erdbeben erholt
erzählt sie im letzten herbst mehr
touristen als je zuvor
[Musik]
auch die schule wurde dort mit
internationalen spenden wieder aufgebaut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
andrea und norbert wurde nun den neuen
traum ihrer eigenen schule vorantreiben
sie haben einen schweizer architekten
gefunden und der hat geld aufgetrieben
er hat ihnen auch vorgefertigte elemente
für den bau aus der schweiz geliefert
doch jetzt gibt es probleme die fracht
blieb hängen und demnächst sollten
freiwillige helfer aus der schweiz
eintreffen um die teile zusammen zu
bauen
ich schlage vor die freiwilligen zu
stoppen
denn was schon sie machen das können wir
nicht machen
die einheimischen wissen nicht wie das
geht
das sind fachleute die wissen wie man
mit dem material umgeht
es ist traurig
das sind die leute die wissen wie man
baut ist dass das verderben haben
vielleicht zieht es bei der nächsten
sitzung schon wieder anders aus am
nächsten morgen bricht andrea mit ihrer
tracking gruppe ab andrea führt ihre
gäste hinauf ins sherpa land näher zum
nordpol wird sie in ein paar tagen
wieder treffen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
norbu bleibt allein zurück in dem basar
sein ziel das café 88 48 hier wird seit
jahren jeden nachmittag der doc des
schweizer fernsehens sherpas die wahren
helden am everest gezeigt mit norbu als
protagonisten vor acht jahren war er
chef sherpa einer schweizer expedition
und damals 28 jahre alt
es ist darüber
norbu befindet sich immer noch im
aufstieg mit ihrem schweren gepäck
kommen die sherpas nur mühsam voran
es ist ein schwieriger job heute den
jeder von uns trägt 25 26 kilo die
teilnehmer alles zurückgelassen
sie tragen nur ihre unterhosen den
daumen anzug und einen kleinen rucksack
wir dürfen uns aber all diese
schwierigkeiten nicht anmerken lassen
wir müssen immer eine fröhliche miene
aufsetzen
da kann man nichts machen das ist die
natur dieses jobs und dann ist es
geschafft
kurz vor neun uhr morgens stehen die
expeditionsteilnehmer von kari kobler
auf dem höchsten gipfel der welt auch
für die sherpas hat es geklappt nach
boostedt zum ersten mal auf dem dach der
welt er entfaltet seine gebetsfahnen um
den göttern zu danken
in gewahrsam
es war seit vier jahren mein traum seit
vier jahren versuche ich auf den mount
everest zu klettern
dieser traum hat sich erfüllt ich bin
hoch erfreut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seither sind sechs weitere gipfel
erfolge dazu gekommen
what a feeling viele gefühle kommen hoch
ein guter freund von mir gestorben
andere sherpa freunde in den vierzigern
bekamen kein job mehr weil sie nicht
mehr so stark waren
da realisierte ich dass das auch mir
passieren könnte
ich sagte mir nein das will ich nicht
ich will nicht erleben dass sie nicht
nicht mehr anstellen weil sie sagen ich
hätte zu wenig kraft
deshalb habe ich meine eigene firma
gegründet
das war ein guter entscheid
am nächsten tag geht norbu andrea
entgegen auf dem weg dorthin will er
zwei sherpas treffen die er seit dem
erdbeben nicht mehr gesehen hat pasang
sherpa und vor butt achim
oberhalb von lampe erwartet ihn das
bergpanorama mit dem everest
es ist wirklich schön beckmann ist
zurück da wo man hingehört
ich bin etwas sentimental und voller
gefühle
gleich neben dem aussichtspunkt trifft
er bereits auf den sherpa führer vor
button der mit seinen jungs unterwegs
ist vorbei sie ist eine legende und hält
mit einem anderen sherpa den rekord an
besteigungen 21 mal stand er auf dem
everest 36 mal auf einem achttausender
auch im frühling 2016 war er wieder im
basecamp
[Musik]
für vorbei tasche hat sich allerdings
vieles verändert ich wollte 2015 den
everest besteigen aber dann kam das
erdbeben und zerstörte das basislager
und ganz nepal nach der lawine im eis
fall war das für uns sherpas das zweite
katastrophenjahr und da fand ich ich
sollte nicht mehr weiter klettern
auch meine eltern baten mich aufzuhören
schon den 21ten aufstieg machte ich ohne
ihre einwilligung
nun klettert er nicht mehr auf dem berg
sondern leitet die sherpas seiner
expedition vom basecamp per funk ist er
mit ihnen in kontakt
502 erreichen unsere sherpas den gipfel
die ersten nach zwei jahren
ich bin so glücklich das ist der
fröhlichste moment er lässt uns die
trauer des letzten jahres vergessen
schober tasche wohnt in kooyong auf
3.780 m
er ist für viele sherpas ein vorbild in
seinem stattlichen haus in welchem er
mit seiner familie lebt nimmt er in der
hochsaison auch gäste auf trecker oder
bergsteigen
vorbei erzählt norbu das sind 90 prozent
aller häuser vom erdbeben beschädigt
worden
sein haus hat er neu aufgebaut nach dem
erdbeben letztes jahr lernten wir die
man erdbebensicherer baut so haben alle
hier bessere häuser als zuvor gebaut
dieses kleine esszimmer ist
erdbebensicher sicher bis stufe sechs
oder sieben glaube ich super tasche hat
sein erspartes vom everest eingesetzt
sowie kredite aufgenommen
aber auch in der übrigen gemeinde von
coaching mit seinen 2000 einwohnern
sieht man nicht mehr viel vom erdbeben
ich mache freiwilligenarbeit um die
stube anzumalen erdbeben wurde sie
zerstört
wir haben sie wieder aufgebaut und jetzt
bemalen sie
für diese stupa bekamen die spenden aus
dem ausland
die great himalaya foundation gab uns
10.000 dollar und einige andere
spendeten auch auch am kloster wird
eifrig gebaut
dafür wurde ebenfalls geld aus dem
ausland gespendet
man spricht von 150000 dollar all das
wurde möglich durch die guten kontakte
zu westlichen bergsteigern als symbol
steht im dorf eine statue des everest
erstbesteiger hillary ist für mich wie
ein gott
ohne ihn hätten wir hier keine schule
er ist wie ein gott für die menschen der
kumpel region
[Applaus]
sechs spielen im leben der sherpas eine
besondere rolle
auch bei vorbei tasche sie liefern milch
fleisch und sind kräftige lasttiere für
das material der expedition
[Musik]
jeden abend kommen die 70 yards von
forbo tasche nach hause und verbringen
die nacht im hof der everest und die
jaxx haben ihn reich gemacht
[Musik]
im hintergrund von kunden die am adapter
auch kurze der nächste ort aufnahm bus
weg liegt nahe bei der anna gabler
es ist ein typisches sherpa dorf auf
3.860 meter 75 seiner männlichen
bewohner waren letztes jahr am everest
im 400 seelen dorf sind noch nicht alle
spuren des erdbebens beseitigt norbu
besucht die familie von pasang sherpa
die er bereits vor dem erdbeben traf
pasang lebt traditionell mit frau kind
mutter und tante im gleichen haushalt
die familie lebt vom einkommen passant
als sherpa am everest pas sans frau nina
war beim erdbeben schwanger und ohne
pasang zuhause stürmte mit der tante
hinaus dass wir draußen waren brachen
wände zusammen
wir alle im dorf versuchten in space
camp zu telefonieren
es funktionierte nicht ich war nervös
als ich hörte dass pasang und seine
kollegen wohl auf waren war ich
erleichtert
bassong war damals am everest und auch
im jahr nach dem beben wieder dort
er erinnert sich noch genau an die
lawine die nach dem erdbeben über das
basecamp fegte die lawine kam von dieser
seite aber auch von der anderen
ich war zu der zeit in meinem zelt meine
freunde brüllten erdbeben
es kam von überall her von der seite und
von oben
am nächsten tag rannten wir zurück nach
hause unterwegs würde ich das mein haus
beschädigt war
aber nur zwei bände war es schwierig für
eine schwangere frau wie bist du das
haus wieder auf die gesammelte steine
und baute es vorne und hinten wieder auf
hat die regierung geholfen nein ohne
etwas gespartes von den expeditionen
hätte es pasang nicht geschafft aber das
geld ist aufgebraucht
und so bleibt das leben der kleinen
schärfer familientag pasang erhofft sich
noch einen zusatzverdienst mit yaks
ähnlich wie vor bei tasche aber mit
einem einzigen tier steht erst am anfang
trotzdem geht es ihm im vergleich zur
bevölkerung weit ab vom everest gut
ohne das einkommen als sherpa liebe nur
der verdienst aus dem kartoffelanbau
[Musik]
am nächsten tag trifft mopo andrea
wieder gemeinsam haben sie etwas
besonderes vor
einen besuch bei lama geschehen er sagte
ihnen vor dem erdbeben das man
gescheiteres machen könne als auf den
everest zu klettern
[Musik]
andrea hat dem diesmal etwas mitgebracht
und ist eigentlich die sehen ja was im
mai 2016 standen sie gemeinsam auf dem
gipfel des everest und blickten auf
seinen schatten ab
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
lammer gesegnet die beiden und wünschte
ihnen viel glück bei ihrem schulprojekt
[Musik]
die beiden verlassen lama geschehe
voller zuversicht
mit dem neuen partner der frau ganze
geschichte und jetzt mit dem schulhof
bauer und die zwei kinder dort ist
einfach hinter mir jetzt schon dabei und
ganz speziell
mit la magisches segen wenden sie sich
nun ihrem neuen projekt zu der schule
fern ab vom everest in der gegend von
dollacker sind sie einige zeit später
auf der fahrt zu ihrem hilfsprojekt
[Musik]
auf dem weg planen sie einen halt in mut
in einem kleinen ort in welchem sie das
heftigste nachbeben der stärke 7,3
erlebten damals wollten sie hilfsgüter
in die besonders zerstörten regionen
bringen
im gegensatz zur everest region ist in
mode noch immer viel zerstört erst jetzt
18 monate nach dem erdbeben wird mit dem
wiederaufbau begonnen
norbu und andrea wurden am 12
mai 2015 auf dieser straße vom nachbeben
überrascht und beschriebene wiener
professioneller überhaupt nicht und sei
dank rechten ort wo an der die erde
bebte ich sah vor mir häuser einstürzen
ich hatte angst denn sie war nicht hier
staubwolken kampf von oben ich rannte
hennen um sie zu suchen
laufen und ganz peter ich darf sie hier
sie rannte herbei und wir gingen
darunter
noch immer sind die spuren des bebens
überall präsent
die fahrt geht weiter nach harry goad
auf 2000 metern
hier wollen sie zum ersten mal ihre
metallischen ingenieur für die schule
treffen
[Musik]
die beiden schildern ihn den
wiederaufbau der zerstörten schule in
laptop und erzählen dass fertigelemente
aus der schweiz unterwegs nach nepal
sind andrea erklärt ihm wie vor
fabrizierte wände mit einer
metallkonstruktion verbunden werden
sollen
erdbeben sicherer als zuvor es wäre gut
wenn sie dem schulleiter genau sagen
könnten wie viel zement er kaufen soll
für das fundament
obwohl spezialisten aus der schweiz den
aufbau leiten sollen braucht es den
nepalesischen an genie der die
erdbebensicherheit des baus gegenüber
den behörden bestätigt nachdem ich es
gesehen habe werde ich die lokalen
anforderungen abklären und alle
dokumente vorbereiten sind alle bereit
für dieses abenteuer
alle sind bereit fürs nepalesisch
schweizerische abenteuer
aber wo bleibt das material
und jetzt machen wir so gut wie möglich
dass gäste aus der stadt wo ich das
motoröl herzliche sehen kalkar zehnter
und hat man doch auch in jerry cotton
sind die spuren des erdbebens noch
allgegenwärtig weitab vom schatten des
everest haben die bewohner mühe mit dem
wiederaufbau dieses haus hier war
zusammengestürzt der zweite stock
existierte nicht mehr
es wird zwar gebaut aber es ist noch ein
weiter weg
in der stadt stoßen die amateur helfern
europa und andrea auf viele
professionelle hilfswerke die ebenfalls
beim aufbau helfen wollen auch sie mit
schwierigkeiten
darunter das rote kreuz das ist bravo 42
architektin vertreterin des
schweizerischen roten kreuzes das
schweizerische arbeitet mit dem
nepalesischen roten kreuz zusammen
die vertreterin vor ort muss schauen
dass das geld korrekt eingesetzt wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch pia bravo ist stundenlang auf den
fürchterlichen straßen dieser gegend
unterwegs nur so gelangt sind die dörfer
die auf die hilfe angewiesen sind
[Musik]
ihr ziel ein modellhaus des roten
kreuzes im dorf zu sparen soll der
gemeinde zeigen wie man ein haus
erdbebensicher gebaut
solche holz bender erhöhen die
erdbebensicherheit
doch viele bewohner leben hier immer
noch in blechhütten viele familien haben
die erste tranche von 500 dollar
bekommen
aber sie bauen nicht vielleicht sollten
wir sie besser informieren was sie mit
dem geld machen können
einige wenige haben mit dem bau begonnen
viele bravo steht mit rat zur seite
haben sie die erste zahlungen der
regierung erhalten
ich bekam 500 us dollar und nahm steine
und material vom alten haus das neue
haus wird etwa 4000 dollar kosten
der hausbesitzer hat den bau unseres
modehauses oft besucht er ist lehrer in
der schule nebenan
er kennt die verbesserungen hat die
traten steine markiert und gut der
ecksteine eingesetzt
aber man könnte das zement band
verbessern
es ist nicht so gut dreyfus wären besser
kamen sie zu unserem büro unser
ingenieur hilft ihm
[Musik]
etwas unterhalb sind andrea und norbert
aufstieg nach lecco dort sollten die
freiwilligen helfer aus der schweiz
eingetroffen sein
[Musik]
es sind spezialisten die in ihrer
freizeit den aufbau der schule
vorantreiben wollen
noch fehlt das material das ist ein
abenteuer zu hause schneit es auch der
nepalesische genie er hilft mit beim
fundament für die neue schule wie kamen
andrea und norbert haupt auf die idee
hier eine schule zu bauen
es war ihre idee
wir verteilten nahrungsmittel und da
sagte sie diese kinder hängen rum die
sollten zur schule gehen daraus sprachen
wir über die schule und das land brauche
jetzt das ist das ist jetzt
und darum wichtig schau mal die
wandtafel die wir ihn mitgebracht haben
die sieht arg mitgenommen aus die sind
auch seit einiger zeit nicht mehr zur
schule gegangen
es macht mich wütend bei der inspektion
stoßen sie auf weitere ungereimtheiten
die vor allem norbu überhaupt nicht
passen
er knöpft sich den schulleiter vor wir
machen das in unserer freizeit wir
werden nicht dafür bezahlt es ist
traurig das zu sehen ehrlich wir
arbeiten sehr hart für dieses tor seit
dem erdbeben haben wir behelfs gebäude
angeschleppt
wir kämpfen in kathmandu für die bauten
und stehen sieben stunden dafür an
wir haben die chance euch so gutes
material zu bringen und wir schenken
euch aber wir geben etwas und ihr müsst
auch etwas geben
wir gehen zurück in die schweiz und da
ist es wichtig dass ihr mithilft die
schule fertig zu bauen
[Musik]
das mache und ich muss jetzt chancen
wenn sie deutsch und das ganze machen
dass das vorjahr
am hang gegenüber im dorf la pila bravo
vom schweizerischen roten kreuz auch
bestrebt die gelder sinnvoll einzusetzen
sie besucht eine 67 jährige frau deren
zweistöckiges familien haus eingestürzt
ist wir können nichts tun
wir haben kein geld um das haus wieder
aufzubauen meine tochter und der
schwiegersohn alle leben hier
das ist unsere situation alle werden
krank in dieser hütte sind dass ihre
enkelkinder
überall wo ich als rotkreuz angestellte
arbeitete haben wir die bedürftigsten
familien unterstützt diese frau wäre
sicher darunter gefallen aber die
regierung lässt eine auswahl von
besonders bedürftigen nicht zu es ist
frustrierend aber wir können nicht gegen
die regierungspolitik handeln
wir sind in nepal wir müssen uns
anpassen das schweizerische rote kreuz
wollte in diesen dörfern 500 häuser für
arme familien bauen aber die
vorschriften der regierung lassen das
nicht zu wir können das geld nicht so
schnell ausgeben wie geplant es ist
schwierig die regierung wechselt immer
wieder hier in nepal
aber wir helfen weiterhin den familien
doch wir können kein geld für den
hausbau ausgeben das schweizerische rote
kreuz hat seine hilfe umgestellt es
bemüht sich einerseits der
landbevölkerung bei der verbesserung
ihres lebensunterhalts unter
wasserversorgung zur seite zu stehen
vela bravo nimmt an einem treffen des
komitees von labil anteil
der lokale rotkreuz mann schildert dass
die meisten familien hier die 500 dollar
der regierung erhalten hätten
aber sie für nahrungsmittel und
nachschub brauchten fast niemand hat die
bahn angefangen
es ist daher umso dringender mittel zu
finden und das einkommen zu verbessern
zum beispiel mit zusätzlichem
gemüseanbau
[Musik]
andererseits forciert das schweizerische
rote kreuz nun die ausbildung von
maurern in einem siebentägigen kurs
lernen hier gestandene handwerker wie
man mit einfachen mitteln die häuser auf
dem land erdbebensichere bauten im
praktischen teil montieren sie daraufhin
selbst metallkonstruktionen die
elastisch genug sind um die erdbeben
resistenz erheblich zu verbessern
nach der ausbildung gibt es eine prüfung
jene welche sie bestehen erhalten ein
offizielles zertifikat der regierung
sie können jetzt beim wiederaufbau ihrer
dörfer helfen sie verbessern ihre
vermittlungsfähigkeit und auch ihre
verdienstmöglichkeiten würden sie als
architektin sie beschäftigen sich wir
brauchen ausgebildete leute mit
kenntnissen
am anderen tag in kleptow schüler und
schülerinnen haben sich herausgeputzt
denn es steht hoher besuch an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ganze dorf und auch die freiwilligen
warten gespannt auf den mann der mit
noro und andrea das ganze möglich
gemacht hat
greg kombinat der architekt der schule
hat sich für ein paar tage zeit genommen
um vor ort einen augenschein zu nehmen
er ist der mann der mit seinen kontakten
das nötige geld aufgetrieben hat die
reise aus der schweiz hatte auf eigene
kosten unternommen andrea und greg
corina werden wie könige empfangen
nach guter nepalesischer tradition
[Musik]
zu ehren der gäste erklingt die
nationalhymne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da ja bald vor danke euch allen den
schweizer freiwilligen und greg kommen
ohne ihn wäre nichts passiert
es ist nur dank norbu und andrea vor
ihnen muss man den hut ziehen
ich habe ein kleines geschenk für jeden
mitgebracht wir möchten euch jetzt
farbstifte verteilen
denn ich bin architekt und farben sind
für mich wichtig ich möchte dass alle
schüler mir ein bild ihre träume main
vielen dank
[Musik]
die 340 schülerinnen und schüler kommen
aus dem dorf und den umliegenden weilern
sie dürfen auf die neue schule hoffen
[Musik]
andrea und norbert haben mich gefragt ob
ich eine schule entwerfen könnte und ich
sagte
ich stand mit voller emotionen hat und
ich glaube das momentane sicher
emotionen gesehen und das geht einfach
so witte sonde weise sich nicht fertig
du bist im frühling am everest gestanden
jetzt stehe ich da was ist wichtiger
das ist auch eine weiß wenn man nicht
nur für sich selbst etwas macht sondern
auch für die anderen noch sitzen die
schüler im provisorium um die
vorgefertigten bauelemente ins dorf zu
transportieren muss zusätzlich eine
straße gebaut werden
auch dass ein teil des projektes genauso
wie die freiwilligen aus der schweiz die
die grundlage für das fundament schaffen
zurück in kathmandu
andrea und norbert sind einen weiten weg
gegangen
vom gipfel des everest quer durch nepal
bis zu ihrer schule
wie sieht ihre zukunft aus
wäre nur egoistisch wären könnte ich
leicht in der schweiz bleiben arbeiten
zusammen sein und ein geregeltes leben
führen
aber wir wollen auch der gemeinschaft
etwas geben nicht nur verdienen junge
fördern
deshalb müssen wir opfer bringen
und die autoren
[Musik]
unterdessen ist die schule in laptop
fertig gebaut
die schüler haben die neuen gebäude in
besitz genommen
[Musik]
eine große hürde ist geschafft
weitere herausforderungen werden sicher
folgen
[Musik]